This segment is going to be very depressing
to many people in the audience, and I do apologize
for that, but it has to be reported because
it's so troubling and atrocious.
The president still doesn't understand viruses
at some general level.
Remember that early in the entire Corona virus
pandemic, we learned from Trump's statements
that he doesn't really understand vaccines.
There were signs that he didn't really understand
the concept, the virus versus bacteria.
He didn't understand the concept of contagion
or of viral spread or exponential growth or
herd immunity or the concept of per-capita
or any of it.
But by now, we would at least hope that he
sort of understands the concept of a virus,
but he still doesn't.
This is a clip from his press briefing on
Friday.
Now, after we listen to it and watch it, we'll
put up a transcript of it on the screen because
it is actually so weaponized that you need
to see it in writing to fully grasp it.
Here is Trump talking about the germ is a
genius and it has figured out how not to be
hurt by antibiotics, which of course, antibiotics
are for bacteria, not for viruses.
Take a look at this brilliant enemy.
They develop drugs like the antibiotics.
You see it?
Antibiotics used to solve every problem.
Now, one of the biggest problems the world
has is the germ has gotten so brilliant that
the antibiotic can't keep up with it.
And they're constantly trying to come up with
a new people, go to a hospital and they catch.
They go for a heart operation.
That's no problem.
But they end up dying from from problems.
You know, the problems I'm talking about,
there's a whole genius to it.
We're fighting.
Not only is it hidden, but it's very smart.
Okay.
It's invisible and it's hidden, but it's it's
very smart.
And you see that in a case like Denver.
But, you know, I think we're doing well and
they're on Denver.
Antibiotics used to solve every problem, he
says, until the germ got brilliant.
And now can avoid it.
Except, of course, Corona virus is a virus.
You don't treat a virus with antibiotics.
Now, let's look at some of this in writing
because it's actually really, really crazy.
Look at what Donald Trump says.
This is a very brilliant enemy.
You know, it's a brilliant enemy.
They develop drugs like antibiotics.
You see it?
Antibiotics used to solve every problem.
Now, one of the biggest problems the world
has is the germ has gotten so brilliant that
the antibiotic can't keep up with it.
And they're constantly trying to come up with
a new people, go to a hospital and they catch
they go for a hard operation.
That's no problem.
But they end up dying from from problems.
You know, the problems I'm talking about.
There's a whole genius to it.
We're fighting not only is it hidden, but
it's very smart.
Okay.
It's invisible and it's hidden, but it's it's
very smart.
And you see that in a case like Denver.
Now, there are some defenders of Trump better
arguing.
Trump is actually very astutely talking about
the problem of antibiotic resistance.
Is there any evidence that suggests Trump
understands antibiotic resistance?
Maybe what Trump meant is that the genius
of the germ is that it chose to be a virus
instead of a bacteria so that antibiotics
wouldn't work against it.
Is that something he has the nuclear codes,
folks.
He has nuclear launch codes and he thinks
a virus is a genius and that it's not affected
by antibiotics as part of that genius.
This reminds me of what might be Donald Trump's
other big crazy unintelligible rant about
Uncle John Trump and nuclear weapons.
There are many highlights or lowlights.
But the genius germ rant reminded me of the
Uncle John Trump rant, which was this one,
remember?
Now what irks me?
Look, having nuclear.
My uncle was a great professor and scientist,
an engineer.
Dr. John Trump at M.I.T..
Good.
Good genes.
Very good genes.
OK.
Very smart.
The Wharton School of Finance.
Very good.
Very smart.
You know, if you're a conservative Republican.
If I were a liberal or if like, OK, if I ran
as a liberal Democrat, they would say I'm
one of the smartest people anywhere in the
world.
But when you're a conservative Republican,
they try oh, do they do a number?
That's why I always sort of went to war.
It was a good student, went there, went there,
did this built for you have to give ballot
credentials all the time?
Because we're at a little disadvantage.
But you look at the nuclear deal.
The thing that really bothers me.
Would've been so easy.
And it's not as important as these lives are.
Nuclear is so powerful.
My uncle explained that to me many, many years
ago.
The power.
And that was 35.
Years ago, he would explain the power of what's
going to happen.
And he was right.
Who would have thought?
But when you look at what's going on with
the four prisoners now used to be three.
Now it's for.
But when it was three.
And even now, I would have said it's all in
the messenger.
Fellas, and it just fellas, because, you know,
they don't they haven't figured that the women
are smarter right now than the men.
So not only is that insane to the degree that
it rivals Trump's more recent genius germ
rant, note also how much more articulate Trump
is in that segment from just a few years ago.
The decline in Trump's speech capacity becomes
even more clear when you look even just a
few years ago, never mind 10 or 15 years ago.
We are really, truly, acutely screwed here,
guys.